Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week on
Game of Thrones so many sad things happened,
this face was my face after it was all over.
They wanted to make us wait a week because
they wanted to give us a break between WTF
moments.
Before we mentally unpack all of them quick
shoutout for the giveaway. Just as a way to
say thank you to you guys for being so awesome
I'm giving away an amazon gift card to a random
subscriber in the comments. All you have to
do to participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment. I'm also willing to send out digital
hugs after what happened.
So first let's do top 5 top WTF moments, then
I'll do my review and circle back around for
any major plot points we need to remember.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it
yet, here we go. Number 5 - Missendei and
Grey Worm 'shipping
This may have been one of the only happy moments
from the episode. The reason it's depressing
is because they'll never be able to consummate
their relationship. I'd argue that shouldn't
stop them from pursuing a companionship that
goes beyond simple friendship, it's just going
to make things really difficult.
Based on the way they left things it seems
like Missandei wants to pursue something with
him, he's the one that seems reluctant. Given
enough time I think he'll come around.
The thing that really struck me about them
is that of all the relationships we saw in
the episode, there's was the only one you
feel good about. Like Roose and Ramsay, Sansa
and Littlefinger. They just creep me out.
Number 4 - Sansa Learns to Lie
Did you see how she died her hair black in
their last scene and they were giving each
other creepy looks. Big red flashing warning
lights going on everywhere. The whole Vale
story this week seemed more about Sansa shedding
most of her innocence, like she's slowly suffocating
the sweet summer child inside her.
As pervy as Littlefinger seems with those
long gazes, his interest in her isn't just
sexual. It's more like he's taking pleasure
in watching her learn to play the game. I'm
really interested to see where they take Sansa's
character from here.
It seems like by the end of this season, the
show will have caught up with book Sansa.
Like when we get to Season 5, for her, the
show will be ahead of the books.
Number 3 - Ser Jorah is Exiled
Poor Ser Jorah, he brought it on himself.
That external shot of the city when he was
riding out of town was so sad. It looked like
it was straight out of a really depressing
western movie. It almost made things worse
that Daenerys didn't scream at him. Like the
moment was so upsetting that she was just
screaming internally. Just like all of us
were screaming internally watching the episode.
What I was confused by was the royal pardon.
He clearly got a copy of it way back in season
1. So was this a new copy? The seal of the
hand of the king was on it. So I'm assuming
what Jorah said was correct, Tywin Lannister
was trying to divide Daenerys inner circle
to keep them busy.
I really hope Jorah isn't gone for the rest
of the season. But it seems like based on
the pacing of the story he'll be on Daenerys
shit list for the rest of this season. So
if we do see him he'll be on his own somewhere.
Number 2 - Ramsay Snow Becomes Ramsay Bolton
This was one of the most twisted victory moments
I've seen this season. Like when something
really awful gets celebrated like Dwarf Jousting
or when a villain wins a big victory like
the Red Wedding. The show even changes the
music to this really uncomfortable tune so
that internally you kind of know not to cheer.
Real quick though, no judging, be honest.
Which of you guys cheered when Roose named
Ramsay Snow a Bolton? My brain kind of melted
a little when it happened.
If there was any doubt that something terrible
just happened, there was that line from Ramsay
telling Reek he'd be giving him a bath later.
Yuck.
That's the best word to describe that whole
part of the story. The flayed Iron Born man
is a visual metaphor for that. In fact, if
any of your friends ever asked you to explain
Ramsay just show them a screencap of this
flayed man. That will tell them everything
they need to know.
I had a hard time telling because the video
I was watching was low rez, but they were
marching toward Moat Cailin way off in the
distance. For a minute it made me think of
Winterfell, because Roose had just got done
making this huge speech about being the Warden
of the North but Winterfell is what you think
when you think of The North.
and my Number 1 WTF moment, pretty easy to
guess Oberyn Martell VS The Mountain.
So many things to unpack here. Let's start
with the fight itself. Pedro Pascal looked
like he was doing all the stunts. What they
did with the fight choreography was so much
better than what I had imagined. And even
though Oberyn got his skull crushed he in
fact did beat the Mountain. He just waited
too long to finish him off.
That wicked looking pike of his was so awesome
too. Here's an up close shot of what the spear
tip looked like. He rammed that through the
Mountain's chest, severed his hamstring and
landed a few other deep slice cuts.
I did a video kind of explaining the Mountain's
armor earlier today, when he's wearing it,
he's basically a walking fortress. So the
only way to land a blow was in the gaps between
plates. On the subject of armor too, even
if Oberyn had been wearing a helmet, the Mountain
still would have been able to crush his head
through it. So don't feel like ignoring Tyrion
had anything to do with him dying.
I shouldn't have been surprised they showed
the wide shot of his body afterwards. Of all
the things the show has done on screen this
season I still think Joffrey's up close purple
face is worse.
At the end of the season I'll do a breakdown
of all the most vomit inducing scenes. Like
a montage of WTF.
For people that have read the books, please
don't go crazy with spoiler in the comments.
The episode cut off right after the Mountain
collapsed. So he's still floating in the ether
even though he got the crap stabbed out of
him.
This will go down as the best fight scene
the show has ever done to date. I challenge
the show runners to top it in a future season.
But now it's your turn. Let me know what your
favorite moment was, and describe the face
you made when the Mountain squished Oberyn's
head.
Overall I felt like this was a B plus episode
with an A plus fight attached at the end.
Usually the different scenes all over the
world connect on a really deep level, but
this week felt a little disconnected. In the
show's defense, that might have been the point.
I think the secret to decoding the episode
is in decoding Orson Lannister. Smashing his
beetles.
I paid special attention to Tyrion's speech,
it was incredibly long. And duration is a
good indicator of how important the showrunners
think something is. Thus, listening to Tyrion
Decode Orson was one of the most important
things in the episode.
I really think they were trying to convey
the idea of futility. Like no one understands
why they're killing all these people. The
beetles being a metaphor for the War of the
Five Kings and on a general level they just
represent any type of killing.
That speech did not end on any kind of resolution.
They didn't answer the question about what
it all means. So I think we're headed for
a lot more senseless violence before the end
of the season.
Let me know what you think the Beetle Speech
was about and what it means for the future.
Really the only hanging threads at the end
of the episode are Tyrion and Arya. Tywin
sentenced him to death, so we need to think
about what's going to happen to him in the
final two hours of the season. Please book
readers, if you're going to post spoilers
be sure to use spoiler tags and just hit enter
four or five times before leaving a comment.
As for Arya, I didn't put it in my Top 5 Moments,
but her reaction to her aunt dying was so
awesome. I think she was laughing just because
it was just one more awful thing that could
have happened. It's like Murphy's Law. Anything
that can go wrong will go wrong. And she's
just laughing at the Universe. I like her
reaction better than Tyrion's reaction. I
guess you could say he's subject to Murphy's
Law too.
Right now the things I'm really looking forward
too is the Wildling Attack on the Night's
Watch, Arya and The Hound. There's really
only a couple more places for them to go.
And finding out what the Martell's are going
to do once they learn Oberyn is dead.
So like usual, my Q&A video will post tomorrow,
be sure to subscribe to get it. I'll try to
post it a little earlier than normal.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I'll add
the annotation as soon as I post it. And click
here for a breakdown of my TOP 10 Fighters
alive or dead on Game of Thrones.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!